is the enforcement learning a good
candidate for achieving general
artificial intelligence at the and are
any other are there any other good
candidates around so they're to me the
answer's no but it can teach us some
valuable gaps that can be filled by
other methods so I believe that
simulation is different than the real
world so it's if you could simulate the
real world then DRL so any kind of
reinforcement learning with deep
representations would be able to achieve
something incredible
but to me simulation is very different
than the real world so you have to
interact in the real world and there you
have to be much more efficient with
learning and to be more efficient
learning you have to have ability to
automatically construct common sense
like common sense reasoning seems to
include like a huge amount of
information that's accumulated over time
and that feels more like programs than
functions
I like how like Ilya sutskever talks
about deep learning learns functions
approximator z' deep RL learns an
approximator for policy or whatever but
not programs it's not learning a thing
that's able to sort of that's
essentially what reasoning is a program
it's not a function
so I think I think no but it'll continue
to one inspires and to inform us about
what the two gaps are I think the
ability to but I'm so human centric but
I think the approach of being able to
take knowledge and put it together sort
of building into more and more
complicated pieces of information
concepts being able to reason in that
way there's there's a lot of
methodologies that old-school sort of
that's the falls under the ideas of
symbolic AI of doing that kind of logic
reasoning accumulating knowledge bases
that's going to be an essential part of
general intelligence but also these
central part of general intelligence is
the roomba that says I'm intelligent if
you if you don't believe me
like a very confident like because right
now like Alexa is very nervous like Oh
what can I do for you
but once the Lexus says like you know is
is upset that you would like turn her
off or treat her like a servant or or
say that she's not intelligent that's
that that's when the intelligence that's
emerging because I think he was a pretty
dumb and what general we're all the
intelligences Anna is a very kind of
relative human construct that we've kind
of convinced each others of and and once
a I systems are also playing that game
of creating constructs and that human
communication that's going to be
important but of course for that you
still need to be have pretty good witty
conversation and for that you need to do
this in Bali I think
you